Ngày 1 món tâm mổn, Nhật Bản Mỹ và Hàn Quốc đã đưa ra phản nướng chính thức sau khi chưa tiền phóng tên lượng.
Già vô biển phía đông bán nào chủ tiền, một có phòng Nhật Bản sáng nhận ít nhất,
hải tiền lợi đã dời xuống vùng đặc quyền kinh tế của Nhật Bản,
sẵn không kinh nhận thi thải.
Tụ tướng, sân nay, ta kê chỉ đã chỉ đạo các quân trưng năng vào đảm án toàn cho tổ tuyên.
Và Hàn không dơ dụng.
Châu kêu đã chơi không hàn phản đối và vối hợp bị Mỹ và Hàn Quốc về vụ việc.
Về việc Mỹ bộ tư lạnh hình dân cho biết.
Lạnh ra bán đào chủ thấy vụ phòng không, gây ra mùi đe dọa tức thị.
Đối với lãnh thổ Mỹ và các nước đối tách trong khu vực.
Còn tại Hàn Quốc, cơ quan là những khu dài đã trưởng tập của học hành.
Nhìn bộ phòng vi phạm các nghỉ quế lên quan của lên của quốc.
Đồng thời, yêu cầu trường tiền chấm rất càng đọc làm gia tăng cân thần.
Phản nướng bộ các nước này, Giễn Xà, sau khi trường tiền tiền thành 2 vụ phòng sáng hình 1 món thông mổn,
bởi tâm bà lên tới chiến chấm năng môi kêu mê vừa tời lãnh thổ nhé bán.